data science business analytics cyber
security cloud computing devops digital
marketing project management and many
more these are some of the skills which
are in demand nowadays
and in future also these skills will be
in demand everybody wants to learn these
skills but most of the people don't know
from where to start and what are the
best resources available in the market
to help you learn these skills simply
learn has this club platform skiller
platform is free of charge available for
everyone who wants to learn new skills
and wants to upgrade themselves all the
courses are free of charge and the bonus
part is that you will also get a free
certificate hey everyone welcome to
simply learn youtube channel in this
video i'll show you all the free courses
that are available on the skiller
platform so without any further delay
let's get started you can find the scala
platform link in the description once
you click on that you will redirect it
to this club platform you will see
explore free courses button once you
click on that you will see the different
course categories such as data science
and business analytics cyber security ai
and machine learning cloud computing
software development digital marketing
and many more all these courses are
designed by industry experts and the
quality of the content is up to the mark
so let's have a look at one of them so
suppose i want to learn programming
languages so what i will do is i will go
to software development category and on
the software development category i will
find c plus plus course java course
python course if i want to learn
blockchain development then also there
is a course available javascript course
is also available and many more
courses related to software development
is available in this particular category
similarly there are multiple categories
you can explore and find the best course
for you
so let's have a look at one of the
courses so i am selecting this java
training
so once i click on that i will redirect
it to the java training course page on
this it is mentioned that you will get 9
hours of self-paced video lessons it
means all the videos are pre-recorded
and it is available on the platform you
can take your own time and watch these
videos and here are some skills which
you will learn after completing this
course so core java 8 concepts you will
learn in this course java ee java
serverlet and many more who should learn
java basics so java architect java
programmer developers can take this
course if you are a student or working
professional you should take this course
below that you will see what you will
learn in java basics so in this section
you will get
all the topics which is covered in this
particular course and this course
includes course completion certificate
and the certificate is free so for all
the courses certificate is free below
that you will see the career
opportunities after doing this course so
java architect the average salary is
around 16 lakh to 17 lakh java developer
where the salary will get is between 4
lakh to 15 lakh and here are some hiring
companies who hire these professionals
and another one is database
administrator you can see the average
salary is between 3 lakh to 13 lakh and
the companies which hire these
professionals and this course comes with
90 days of access so you have sufficient
time to complete this course
so now let's have a look at some another
category it is not just about id on
skill up you will get free courses from
other field as well like digital
marketing business and leadership so
firstly let's have a look on digital
marketing courses on the digital
marketing category you will find
lot of free courses when it comes to
social media when it comes to content
marketing ppc youtube and video
marketing facebook marketing
digital marketing strategy advanced
mobile marketing instagram marketing so
platform wise courses are also available
like instagram course linkedin course
youtube course and lot of other courses
are available like snapchat course is
also there
most of the people think that only
technical skills matters the most but it
is not true
if you want to grow in your career you
need the business and leadership skills
as well so now finally let's have a look
on the business and leadership category
on this category you will get lot of
business analysis
related courses design thinking for
business digital leadership and business
course this is also a really good course
and one course which i would recommend
to you is interview preparation so
suppose if you are a fresher and looking
for a job and have learned all the
skills which is required to that
particular job but most of the people
fail in the interview and that's why we
have prepared this course for you this
is a one hour course has a course
completion certificate and 90 days of
access which is more than enough and you
will acquire skills like making a good
resume creating a good first impression
and many more things which is required
to get your first job we have looked in
few categories similarly you can have a
look on all these categories and
whichever category you like you can go
and select the courses which you want to
learn so i hope now you have a better
understanding of this club platform in
case you have any queries feel free to
drop your queries in the comment section
and our team of experts will be more
than happy to resolve your queries at
the end yes hit that like button if you
enjoyed watching this video and if you
are new to this channel then subscribe
to simply dance youtube channel
thank you so much for joining in stay
safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here